chaque vendredi une vingtaine de
salariés basée sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines se retrouve
sur le parvis du vélodrome nationale
après quelques minutes d'échauffement
c'est parti pour une demi heure de
footing
encadré par un coach sportif du cdh
alliés course un pied en même temps
exercices de renforcement musculaire
un gros point positif surtout pour
l'esprit sportif et la stricte équipe
parce qu'ils font la course en équipe
tous ont un même objectif se préparer au
mieux pour le trophée des entreprises
qui aura lieu le 13 juin prochain et
après 45 minutes d'effort très bien ça
permet d'aller plus loin que si j'étais
tout seul
du coup pour ça je suis content c'est
sympa de voir les concurrents les
adversaires et aussi de m'entraîner avec
mes coéquipiers pour renforcer l'esprit
d'équipé possible
c'est sympa l'année dernière 600
personnes ont participé à ce raid
multisports plusieurs épreuves attendre
les équipes course à pied course
d'orientation encore relais vtt
si certains participent pour gagner
d'autres on tend tout autre objectif pas
dernière s'amuser parmi les épreuves
redouté par ses participantes celle du
radeau dans le cadre de cette
préparation saint quentin en yvelines
propose de vous familiariser avec
embarcations et vous donne rendez vous
le mercredi 12 juin de 18h à 19h30 sur
l'île de loisirs